for today's classic interview very
relevant my interview from two years ago
to the day with Steve Almond who argues
that football the sport that he loved
for so long is immoral and we shouldn't
watch it and since this interview we've
of course learned after the death of
former New England Patriots player Aaron
Hernandez that even though he was quite
young and relatively early in his career
he was suffering from severe CTE chronic
traumatic encephalopathy brain injury
and we've had this entire blow-up
regarding kneeling during national
anthem so I think that there is no
better time to go back to my interview
with Steve Almond from October fifth of
two years ago 2015 let's check it out
I'm joined today by Steve almond author
of against football one fans reluctant
manifesto which is just out in paperback
the book is super interesting Steve and
you're an admitted football fan who is
sort of trying to rid yourself of
football and you have a number of
ethical concerns around the game which
we'll get to and you know in in
preparing for this interview I was
reminded of an interview I did with the
nation's Dave Zirin around the last
World Cup where he presented all sorts
of very strong indictments of FIFA and
of World Cups more broadly but still
said he doesn't think it's unethical or
immoral to watch because you enjoy the
game of soccer but that you should be
simultaneously advocating for change now
when it comes to football for you you
you feel that that is not an OK solution
in other words you really need to rid
yourself of football as you say well I I
think that's a the book is trying to
present the football for what it really
is the biggest central narrative in
American culture the most popular sport
the most profitable sport the largest
activity or narrative that we all have
in common I think it's bigger than
religion at this point it's bigger than
the bonds of family in many cases and
I'm really interested in what it means
both as a phenomenally interesting game
narrative and also maybe even as almost
like a spiritual thing for a lot of
people but also what the dark side of it
is so the book isn't trying to say you
should do this or you should do that but
you should know exactly what it is
you're sponsoring when you sit down to
watch a game and I think that's the
place where I do depart from somebody
like Dave's ayran although I really
appreciate how intelligently he writes
about sports and how morally grounded he
is as a commentator I think it's very
basic Roger Goodell and the folks who
run the big college football programs
and the whole football industrial
complex they don't care whether your
guilt stricken they don't care whether
you are sort of cheering with the big
foam rubber hand in one hand and maybe
with a fist advocating with the other
because they're really keeping score in
a very basic way
are you a sponsor are you tuning in are
you contributing to the revenues of big
football and the answer is yes if you're
a fan that's what you're doing but
that's my answer there are a lot of
people who are going to read the book
and say well I might cut back on my
consumption or I might become more
active and involved when it comes to
questioning how my tax dollars are spent
at the level of high school or pro or
college football so it's not trying to
advocate any one solution like boycott
football it's much more hey you should
think about what everything that
football is because it's extraordinarily
complicated and it's woven through the
fabric of almost everything we do in
America at this point
give us the sort of bullet points of
what these areas of concern are and then
you know I have some that I'm going to
want to dive into the ones that to me
strike me are of course the this
pervasive brain injury disaster and
systematic cover-up that has been
exposed several times now right and and
how that impacts how we see college
football and even high school football
really right the corporatism no question
about that the greed which some right
off is sort of billionaires versus
millionaires which is not at all the
reality as Dave's iron has exposed when
we look at owners versus players what
else is there well I think there are
things that are a little
that squishier and more subtle but you
know the major thing is that you have to
accept that you're watching a form of
entertainment in which you incur none of
the risk and in which up to a third of
the pro players are gonna get brain
damage that's the big one that for me
having seen my mom suffer a cognitive
collapse basically I just just kind of
turned my stomach but beyond that and
beyond the sort of the greed that's just
sort of built into American capitalist
culture our issues that have to do with
the way that masculinity is defined and
femininity the way that sort of gender
and orientation work and I think the
main thing that really troubled me the
more I thought about two things really
the way in which football has become
inextricably linked to the educational
process in this country at the high
school and college level that just makes
no sense to me that a game that that
essentially segregates people and values
them purely for their physical worth and
that also clearly now the research
indicates has deleterious effects on
people's brain function somehow are a
huge part of our educational system and
the tax dollars that are spent on it and
the other thing is that it really
sanitizes and normalizes violence I
think in this way it's symptomatic of
American culture but the thing about
football that just makes it distinct
from something like rugby or especially
boxing is we really come to believe as
when we watch football we we allow a
certain kind of magical thinking to
infect us we honestly think that a
280-pound player who comes up against
another 300-pound player you know with
70 g-forces maybe a hundred times a game
isn't going to be permanently damaged
and maybe even brain damaged by that
contact we allow ourselves to believe
that it's not real violence and I think
that abstracting of what real violence
is and it's real human toll is the same
mentality that's an operation when for
instance we send soldiers overseas and
they suffer whatever they suffer and
then when they come back to the United
States we just aren't particularly
interested in their suffering do you
think that well let me frame in a
different way there's many people I know
who if I said to them you know football
really has this inherent tolerance for
what are debilitating brain injuries to
a significant
the players football really has this
tolerance for this total corporatism
football tolerates even arguably
homophobia and even racism in some cases
bla bla bla and they would look at me
and with a totally straight face they
would say David I know what you're
saying but I just like watching the game
I don't believe any of those things and
watching the game isn't going to change
my opinion is that a valid defense in
your mind or are you legitimizing those
problems merely by watching I don't know
that you're legitimizing them I think
you're consuming and really in that way
kind of taking part in a game that has
certain values that that we really would
never can tell condone outside the realm
of football that's what's so amazing
about football it's such a remarkable
spectacle it's so thrilling and our
attachment to it is so deep that we
essentially throw whatever moral qualms
we might have out as citizens as parents
you know as maybe even as people of
faith those go out the window you know
if you think about how Jesus would
regard the Jesus I'm talking about sort
of the Sermon on the Mount who has
turned the other cheek avoid violence
right not the evangelical right-wing
Jesus well right the guy who was you
know turning over the the money changers
tables who was a radical who believed in
the gospel of love as a revolutionary
force yeah Jesus would look at football
and say oh I recognize that the nearest
cognate I have is the spectacles that
the Romans throw these gladiatorial
combats where there's clear blood lust
there's a clear effort to distract the
people from incompetent Vino leadership
and from a kind of injustice that I am
trying to my whole mission is to put
across that we've got to be more
merciful and kind and less violent
towards one another but there you know a
lot of people would say they believe in
what Jesus said on the Mount and then
they would you know watch a football
game and when runningback scores a
touchdown by knocking the linebacker
senseless and says thank God thank God
I'm glad you know both even God I'm glad
he was watching over this gridiron they
were no sense of cognitive dissonance
but in this sense David it's really um
it's more typical of an American human
but especially an American mindset that
is we love certain pleasures in this
culture but we don't like interrogating
those pleasures morally it's very
unpleasant we all love bacon or most of
us do but we certainly have no interest
in going to the slaughterhouse what my
book is attempting to do is to say look
I loved football for 40 years as a as if
as a sport and as a spectacle its
ecstatic and beautiful it's the body at
play its greatness and poise and
discipline and teamwork and all these
virtues many of them manly but still
virtues that are nothing but laudable
and also while you're consuming all that
there's also this other stuff and this
other stuff is really you're a part of
this larger system that Foster's that
you you talk about homophobia as like
maybe the NFL is homophobic it's not a
maybe when you have a collective freaked
out at the idea that a single gay
employee is going to enter your work
life that's just when you look at any
other workplace we would never would
never accept that maybe the Catholic
Church or you know an evangelical
business but we would never accept that
in most other realms of our life just
like we would never accept a workplace
where the ownership says yeah 30% of the
employees are gonna get long term
cognitive ailments but what are you
gonna do it's just they incur the risk
they know what they're doing
you know we don't watch coal miners get
black lung right but we could all
recognize that it was a real problem and
they the workplace needed to change we
are actually watching the coal miners
get black lung that's what we're doing
every Sunday we're watching guys who are
getting brain damage and we're seeing
some of them take their own lives or
sort of suffer in silence years later
and we're saying collectively and
individually I'm ok with that
and have you successfully stayed away
from watching football the first three
weeks of the current season you know I
have to say I have but it's not easy
because it you know because I am a
sports fan I check to see you know
what's going on with the baseball team I
follow and are there any interesting
highlights and also sports is on
everywhere it's sort of the national
wallpaper and
ice to notice that my team the
long-suffering Oakland Raiders seemed to
somehow miraculously not be doing
terribly in fact doing surprisingly well
so now the real challenge comes in its
yeah your team is lousy and you turn
away it's when your team is doing great
and you you know then have to turn away
and I just want to say it's not like I'm
loving it we're just sitting there going
oh well what a dumb game and I can't
believe I ever watched it I know exactly
why I watched it it's unbelievably
alluring and all my book is trying to do
is say it's what is it like when you
have to walk away from something you
really love because you learned so much
about it that you realize there's a lot
of unlovable parts to it that are sort
of infecting you without you're entirely
realizing it let me remind everybody the
book is called against football one fans
reluctant manifesto it's now out in
paperback we've been speaking with the
book's author Steve Almond thank you so
much for telling us about it absolutely
thank you